alright as of now there's about a week
until the Dark Knight Rises comes out so
let's celebrate that fact by talking
about this piece of [ __ ] Batman and the
death of a franchise otherwise known as
Batman and Robin official Batman and
Robin came out a couple years after
Batman Forever and at no point was like
oh they're going to learn from their
mistakes from the last movie and improve
on this movie I never thought that I saw
the trailer and I was like new Batman
movie gotta say I was a kid then and
apparently not a very bright one person
when Batman and Robin you have George
Clooney as Batman which makes Val
Kilmer's Batman look like The Dark
Knight as he should and would and could
ever be George Clooney is Batman he's
just pops I was like hi freeze I'm
Batman really that's the best you got
and asking that he sounds like he has
throat cancer like Christian Bale or
anything like that but at least act like
it's a different persona just a dude in
a cape the movie starts out complete
cheese the first line in the movie is
Robin going I want a car chicks dig the
car Batman's like this is why Superman
works alone wait a minute you mean
Superman does exist in the Joel
Schumacher universe so and freeze it's
freezing the entire city at Gotham where
is he does he just not give a [ __ ] has
he ruined Superman to the horror then
robin turns to alfred he's like don't
wait up for me Allan Alfred's like out
of Kensu the pizzas those are honestly
the first lines and pieces of dialogue
in this entire movie sets the entire
stage you're like it's gonna go from bad
to worse isn't it yeah it is in
Commissioner Gordon comes on the little
bat TV in the Batmobile and talks to
Batman like some sort of radio announcer
from Little Orphan Annie or the shadow
yeah you know the ham radio ones from a
Christmas story is all I got man we have
a new villain in Gotham City he's
calling himself mr. freeze he's turned
the guards in the blocks of ice it has
now gone from bad to worse not as bad as
it's gonna be and from there is just a
plethora of illogic and garbage right
Arnold Schwarzenegger is mr. freeze I
never thought that would ever work ever
I always thought Patrick Stewart would
have been a good mr. freeze everyone is
on a wire in this movie I think everyone
from the moment they started filming
even extras are like we're gonna strap
you into these harnesses with wires
because at a point you're going to
unrealistically fly through the air and
no one's gonna buy it it's going to look
terrible quite as bad as the reverse
motion when Robin was coming out of the
water I like hmm yeah they like rewound
the footage but it's still pretty bad
and then you
have a Thurmond who was nominated for an
Oscar before this movie came out
watching her in this movie you're like
there is no way this woman could have
ever been nominated for anything other
than a Razzie when she acts it's just
like in the plants you are tormenting
them I'll seek justice you psycho and
then you have Bain in this movie and
they completely destroyed Bain he's not
Bain he's a sasquatch with no hair
that's what he is he's a sasquatch on
chemo he's a big idiot he's a like and
the premise in this movie is that Mr
Freeze is gathering a bunch of diamonds
because his suit runs on diamonds he's
making a big diamond gun that's going to
freeze Gotham City to hold Gotham City
for ransom for billions of dollars so we
can find a cure for his wife he's
cryogenically frozen did that sound a
stupid just now you hearing it as me
saying it yeah I think it did why
because like I said his suit runs on
diamonds and he has like a dozen and a
half diamonds that are this big around
just cash them in and then have your
money and then get a cure spending
billions of dollars to get billions of
dollars of ransom it's just shitty
business I'm Alicia Silverstone is
Batgirl of one thing to say there you go
and that's that the movies completely
over acted it's all over the top nothing
makes any sense in this movie Arnold
Schwarzenegger only says one liners in
this movie The Iceman Cometh I hated
with people talk during the movie come
on employees sing loudest Fame what
killed the dinosaurs the Ice Age which
is funny because he shoots this
brontosaurus dinosaur statue and freezes
it and falls down it really doesn't do
anything it's not like anyone was on it
it's not like it was a support beam
holding the building up just kind of
froze and shattered on the ground and
that was it you can really pick this
movie apart in every scene in it like
there's a scene where this Rockets going
up Batman's in it the little altimeter
on this rocket is freezing cuz it's
getting so cold up there but Robins
climbing the rocket from the outside
he's you know alive wouldn't he freeze
to death and die it's really rhetorical
he would freeze to death and die you
guys notice the icicles in this movie
when things are frozen like that cop
opens this cop door and the icicles are
all like wobbling like that that's the
best they got I mean this shitty acting
you think all right Joel Schumacher's
just cashing his friends in this movie
so that's why they're shed but the props
you really said that was okay come on
and then I was watching the special
features in this movie because I was
like I want to hear them BS their way
through these interviews and try to even
justify this movie
none of them do Chris O'Donnell was like
yeah I felt like I was filming a
commercial for toys the entire time and
the funny thing is these special
features tell why this movie looks like
a big commercial for toys because it is
a commercial for toys I mean if you look
at the Batmobile if it ever looked like
a stupid toy to you that's because it
was made to be a toy they actually
designed everything in this movie to be
action figures and toy vehicles before
the movie actually went into production
the toys are not the byproduct of the
movie the movie is a byproduct of the
toys that is movie production fail 101
right there you never do that but they
did it and this is what we have being
said anyone else is thinking about doing
something like that
don't do it the movie was created to
make toys and that's actually a fact
that men in Robin is the epitome of dog
[ __ ] and Joel Schumacher to his credit
takes the blame on his shoulders he was
like I was a director I am sorry he got
to give him credit for that he was like
yeah this is terrible mess
apologies trying to fun dark [ __ ] though
I mean the movie does give you content
to roast with your friends like if you
got the drinks going the rum and cokes
the shock tops you guys are like let's
roast a movie like Mystery Science
Theater let's pop in Batman and Robin
actually it's kind of fun sometimes
other than that Batman and Robin's one
contribution to movies is this if Batman
didn't fall so far from grace so hard I
really don't think Warner Brothers would
have been open to the idea of rebooting
Batman like Christopher Nolan's Batman
Begins you know like a really realistic
Batman I think if they were gonna reboot
Batman they'd be like all right let's
make a comic book ish Batman because
that's what Batman is so if it led to
Batman Begins somehow awesome that being
said it gets no credit for anything in
life and just to be fun I'm gonna put
this link in the description below
before I did movie reviews I actually
made a couple of fan made trailers I
made like three of them that's just what
I did one of them was Batman and Robin I
wanted to see if I can make Batman and
Robin look like a good movie it's on my
old account I put the link below in this
video go check it out let me know what
you think there are a couple things in
that video that I would tweak and
tighten up but it was like the second
thing I ever edited so you know whatever
I'm not even gonna ask you what you
think of Batman and Robin because I know
it's okay it's okay we're all here we're
all friends you can talk about it screw
it though what is the worst movie ever
made to you whatever that invokes
whatever movie comes to your mind when I
say that comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more loud insane
you